for me I just always wanted to try and
eat healthier first she let us inside
her fridge stocked with healthy foods or
should we say fridges then if you want a
little more chaos with tons of oat milk
and almond milk you have this frigerator
and now Kim Kardashian is taking it a
step further by giving fans a detailed
breakdown of her diet bands they're like
these are the types of questions we
wanted to hear the mama for did a little
Q&A Monday on Twitter answering
questions ranging from what she eats for
breakfast to her favorite cheat meal
when one fan acts Kim would she ever go
vegan she let them know that she eats
mostly plant-based now no meat anymore
something she actually spoke on during
that fridge tour look what I have for
dinner tonight guys vegan tacos this is
all plant-based when it comes to the
kids Kim revealed that they also eat a
plant-based diet well except for North
who was a pescetarian whatever she wants
to do when she is old enough she can do
for breakfast and lunch kim's go to sour
oatmeal and vegan sausage during the am
and vegan tacos and salads for lunch she
also enjoys CMOS movies which are said
to be immune system boosters
I love junk this now Kim does like to
indulge a bit when asked about her
favorite snack she listed a few cheetos
cheetos puffs and doritos
asked for her favorite cheat mill Eggos
or top ramen at home but it really
depends on what city she's in the
questions continue to roll in but a
little after an hour the reality star
decided that it was time for her to go
to bed I am exhausted that means Kim
left questions like these unanswered but
hopefully there's more Q&A time to come
as we know kim built her career off of
revealing intimate details about her
life but she does think before sharing
too much with her followers here's what
she told et in 2018 I think if you have
any questions about it don't share it
that's the one thing like I'm I'm never
not proud of anything that I have shared
you know but at the time it might be
something that I was so excited to post
and now I could look back and be like
well I might not post that today but I
have like no regrets at that time I was
really feeling it so just don't be
impulsive you know I think think it
through think about if you want people
to know this information cuz it'll
always be there and that will never
change but I think you know social media
is such a great tool but of course you
need boundaries I think everyone does
[Music]